congratulations on making it this far
I just wanna wrap up and leave you with
a few final thoughts
we've been on quite a journey together
but if you've taken the whole
specialization then you've learned about
new networks and deep learning how to
improve deep neural networks of the
structure machine learning projects
convolutional neural networks and then
in this most recent course sequence
models and I know you work really hard
and I also hope you feel very proud of
yourself for your hard work and for how
much you've done so I want to leave you
one
maybe important thought which is that I
think deep learning is a superpower with
deep learning algorithms you can make a
computer see you can have a computer
synthesize novel art or synthesized
music you can have a computer translate
from one language to another maybe have
it locally radiology image and render a
medical diagnosis or build pieces of a
car that can drive itself and if that
isn't a superpower I don't know what is
and as we wrap up this sequence of
courses as we wrap up this
specialization I hope that you will find
ways to use these ideas to further your
career to pursue your dreams but perhaps
most important to do whatever you think
is the best work you can do or humanity
the world today has challenges but with
the power of a on power of deep learning
I think we can make it a much better
place and now that you have this
superpower I hope you will use it to go
out there and make life better for
yourself but also for other people and
of course I also hope you feel very
proud of your accomplishments in the
powerful you've come and of all that
you've learned and when you complete
this sequence of courses you should also
share it on social media like Twitter or
Facebook and let your friends know and
finally the very last thing I want to
say to you is congratulations on
Nicholas I hope you feel great about
your accomplishments but also I want to
thank you very much I know that you have
a busy life but despite that spends a
lot of time watching these videos and
maybe spent a long time also working on
the quizzes and the programming
exercises I hope you enjoyed it and you
got a lot out of the process but I'm
also very grateful for all your time you
spend and for all your hearts wherever
you put into learning these materials so
thank you very much